auf jeden fall eine partie über die
jetzt ganz deutschland spricht und
deswegen bei mir jetzt mein kollege aus
unserem show herbstmorgen erstmal hauke
wir haben jetzt diese aufnahmen exklusiv
zugespielt bekommen wie muss man sich
vorstellen wie konnte das ganze so
ablaufen
die drei aber informatik sind jetzt zu
ende gegangen ganz offiziell das ist
auch mitgeteilt worden
und ja die macher hatten halt lust den
schluss dieses langen drehs zu feiern
die waren ja seit februar ende februar
in berlin habe mir lange gedreht und
wollten diesen schlusstag eben mit ihren
freunden und teil der crew halt begehen
tja und dann haben sie sich überlegt wie
kriegen wir das hin bei momentan den
corona darf ja keiner feiern party ist
absolut verboten
zu recht und dann hat man sich in
kleinen trick überlegt oder würde ich
sagen das war ein guter trick dass man
gesagt hat okay wir machen einen drehtag
ein party szene wird dann gedreht und
das wird ein drehtag und keine offiziell
keine party jetzt sehen wir die bilder
von dieser party und wir konnten auch
mit jemandem sprechen der selber dort
war einmal und die ersten eindrücke
reinholen wie also dieser dreh oder doch
eher gesagt diese party so ablief
bevor alle reingelassen worden sind
mussten alle zum corona schnelltest der
wurde durchgeführt danach durfte man
erst in die eigentliche halle rein und
man wurde auch angehalten die maske zu
tragen natürlich piano riefen seine
freunde sind relativ früh gegangen saßen
beide eigentlich ganz deutlich im
wohnwagen also drin gab es auch drei
wohnwagen und da saßen sich den ganzen
abend davor warnt sich nett unterhalten
ganz entspannen haben das ganze
interview mit dem party gast in der
augenzeugin dann später in unserer 12
uhr sendung aber auge das klingt alles
nicht nach dreharbeiten sondern nach
einer party wie sie auch alle noch aus
den zeiten vor corona kennen gibt es da
jetzt schon irgendwelche äußeren
gleichung rief selber er war ja da wir
jetzt gerade gehört haben von kerne rief
selber nicht aber
von sage ich mal der stelle wo diese
party stattgefunden hat die hat nämlich
ja nicht irgendwo in irgendeinem club
sondern auf dem gelände und den studio
babelsberg statt gefunden wo der vierte
teil auch gedreht worden ist in den
letzten monaten und natürlich haben wir
danach gefragt und gesagt wie kann das
passieren dass dort eine party gefeiert
wird und die sprecherin der studio
babelsberg hat gesagt dass der mieter
die produktionsfirma ist und die mieter
die produktionsfirma eben von matrix hat
diesen hat dann offiziell gesagt das ist
ein dreh der da stattfindet bei dem
natürlich die gängigen hygiene konzepte
eingehalten werden also abstand macht
getragen nicht so viele leute in einem
raum und dass das damit im grunde für
die klar erledigt ist ne dieser
offiziell ist es halt einen dreh termin
gewesen
und dann ist natürlich die frage war das
genehmigt und dazu haben wir auch schon
eine stellungnahme von der stadt dazu
der dreh ist so per se explizit nicht
genehmigt worden der gesamte matrix tree
ist natürlich genehmigt worden auch
immer wieder abgestimmt worden in den
letzten monaten weil sich ja die lage
auch in deutschland verändert hat aber
das ist im grunde nicht angemeldet
gewesen musste auch nicht sein denn
keiner kann natürlich hinter die
kulissen gucken was da genau passiert
aber wie es ausschaut werden mehrere
zeugen gesprochen eben wurde da gar
nicht gedreht wie das offiziell als
sondern es wurde gefeiert
ich weiß ja gerade schon babelsberg
angesprochen die sagen an sich ist
natürlich wanner dafür zuständig was sie
da machen
jetzt werden babelsberg und die
verantwortlichen diese videos und bilder
auch gesehen haben sonst da dann
konsequenzen für geben wir mit der stadt
potsdam gesprochen und ein sprecher hat
jetzt gesagt dass sie diesen fall jetzt
bewerten
das ist man sich die bilder anschaut und
man damit den studio babelsberg kontakt
aufnimmt und dass es dazu eine anhörung
gibt und man sich diesen fall erstmal
jetzt heute und die nächsten tage
anguckt und das dann bewertet und das
studio babelsberg erstmal dazu befragen
wird was da passiert ist und wie es da
ja wie es dazu kommen konnte oder lässt
sich ja schon eigentlich ausschließen
aber wie
wie im grunde das zu dem wurde was ist
ja wahr wie konnte andré zu einer party
werden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren